[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
my
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
so
good evening friends of the table
we're so grateful to have you here and
to share this space with you every week
and we just want to welcome you if this
is your first time
and you just happen to be
trying it out or seeing what's up or if
you've been here with us
for the long haul you are so welcome
and um just very loved and appreciated
guys we are um continuing to
miss being physically present to one
another on our
sunday night services and we just hope
you know that
in um the midst of this season
you are not forgotten whoever you
are whatever you are going through if
you are here
we are regularly praying for you and
lifting you up our leadership team
mentions you by name in our prayers and
um we hold you in our hearts whatever
it is that might be going on in your
life right now i hope you know
that you are not forgotten and you are
not alone
and we want to be here for one another
during this season
just as much as we ever have been um
i feel like it's common to hear people
say things like you know there's no
problem
too big that god cannot handle and
i just also want to remind you there's
also no problem too
small that is unimportant for god
and um i hope you feel seen in whatever
you're going through in your life right
now
i hope you feel seen and loved and
the prayer of my heart and i know that
that's shared by the people here at the
table
is that that would be true for you and
um
we just want to communicate our love and
appreciation for all of you
and um i was just
reminded in scripture um from
second corinthians um the apostle paul
talks about
you know the struggles that he faced and
the times that he would beg for god to
just take it away just
get rid of it get it out of my life just
fix it fix the problem please get it out
of my life
and god's response to him was my grace
is sufficient for you
for my power is made perfect in your
weakness
and so um yeah i just pray that you can
find god's power at work in your life
right now even in the weak spots even in
the places where it feels like
we just need something to go right
we need something to get fixed and
i think that's you know a little bit of
our national state as well right now but
anyways we're here together in this so
don't give up and don't hesitate to call
out
i did have one announcement for you guys
before we transition into our worship
service tonight
and that is that we have a welcome to
the table class
that will be offered on october 11th
sunday night
directly after the service at 6 15 for
anyone who is
interested in learning more about just
who we are or what we're about at the
table
if you want to um look into how do i
join this church
how do i become a member or if you're
looking for just more information about
where we came from and what our values
are or just how to get plugged in
we would love for you to sign up there's
going to be a link posted in the
comments
for you and so please check that out or
click on that if you're interested in
that class
we would love to have you there so i'm
going to turn it over to mindy and she's
going to be
kicking off our worship time tonight and
we just pray it's a blessing to all of
you
so welcome and thank you mindy
hey guys yeah
good to be with you um i'm gonna do
a couple songs real quick and as i was
working on the worship for this week i
was just
excited really about what god what god
is um kind of putting on brett's heart
to share about for the next few weeks
and what we're going to be hearing and
remembering some of the songs from me
that have reminded
reminded me when i have questions or
doubts
or when i'm not sure exactly
um what to do
with difficult things how to interpret
them
how to read them what to do with the
bible
all of that there are a few songs to me
that have just been really helpful and
true
no matter what and i hope that these
songs
feel true for you as well um so as i
seeing them
i'm singing it as kind of truth for my
life and as a prayer for yours that you
will feel
the god that is constantly coming
into our situations and turning
ashes into beauty and um
loving and accepting us and
for us on our side walking beside us
in both the good and the bad so
um forgive me i am a little congested
congested from allergies so
uh that's probably gonna show up
[Music]
my soul cries out
my soul cries out for
you
these bones cry out
these bones cry out for you
to live and move cause
only
[Music]
my soul cries out
my soul cries out for
you
jesus you're the one who saves
us constantly creates us
into something new
jesus surely you will find
us surely our messiah
we'll make all things new
jesus surely you will save
us constantly create us
into something new
jesus surely you will
find us surely our messiah
will make all things new will make
things new hey
we'll make all things new
hey we'll make all things new
come and make me new
you made me new again
i know that you are for me
i know that you will never
forsake me in my weakness
and i know that you have come now
even if to ride upon my heart
to remind me of who
you are
so faithful
so constant
so loving and so true
so powerful and all you do
you feel me
you see me
and you know my every move
and you love me to sing to
you
and i know that you are for me
i know that you will never
forsake me in my weakness
and i know that you have come now
even if to ride upon my heart
to remind me of who you
[Music]
are
so patient
so gracious
so merciful and true
so wonderful and all you do
you fill me
you see me
[Music]
and you know my every move
and you love me to sing to
[Music]
i know that you are for me
i know that you will never
forsake me in my weakness
and i know that you have come now
even if to ride upon
my heart
to remind me of who
you are
cause love is breaking not
it's breaking
love is breaking
out it's breaking up
oh your love
is breaking through
it's breaking through
oh your life
is breaking through
it's breaking through
and i know that you are for me
i know that you are for me
i know that you will never
forsake me in my weakness
i know that you have come now
even if to ride upon
my heart
to remind me of who
you are
thank you mindy i uh i'm sure you missed
worshiping with everybody
i was playing along with you
so i'm gonna sing your love by third day
i i did the song back in the springtime
and i uh i added an extra verse it's not
in the song originally
kind of inspired by the events of you
know
what we're all going through within the
startup of covet 19.
and uh the verse is your love o lord
reaches to the millions who now live
life in desperate solitude
your love is the light shining in the
darkness
so the tired and weary
can find their way to you so so when i
wrote those words it was
basically for everybody
and and those words are for everybody
but uh
just recently those words started to
take on a more personal
meaning for me because my mother passed
away last night
and she was living in a
nursing home and she was you know
she wasn't able to be visited by her
family her family wasn't able to visit
her we couldn't get hugs from her she
couldn't get hugs from us
and um so yeah
um
so my mother she supported all of her
kids um
for everything that we wanted to do she
supported us and
as long as it wasn't you know being
hooligans
you know she was she was good with it
you know and she and
my my brothers and sisters and i were
as different as the colors in a rainbow
and that was okay
and um so for me it was music
and so it just didn't seem right to not
sing
and worship the lord today because if i
canceled it just went beyond her in her
memory
so so here i am
um i've been thinking a lot about
pain and sorrow and loneliness
and
[Music]
and um it's framed differently this year
but it's all those those things have
always been around
um but another constant that has been
through all of this
is the lord and he never changes
his love his faithfulness and his
righteousness
have always been there and when things
are dark
he is the light
that will get us through
[Music]
your love old lord
reaches to the heavens
[Music]
your faithfulness
stretches through the sky
your righteousness
it's like the mighty mountains
[Music]
you're just
to worship you like
i won't find my strength
[Music]
in the shadow on your way
reaches to the heavens your faithfulness
stretches to the sky
[Music]
your righteousness
is
[Music]
i won't find
worship
[Music]
is
you love old lord
reaches to the millions
[Music]
who now live life
desperate solitude
with your love's all light
shining in the darkness
so the tired and weary may
find their way to you
and we will lift our voice
to worship you our
king
we will find our strength
[Music]
we will lift our voice
to worship you our
king
we will find our strength
in the shadows
[Music]
you
shining in the darkness
[Music]
shining in the dark
beautiful beautiful thank you carter
thank you for
um just sharing that that with us and
helping us connect with god in and
through
your kind of your own loss and your your
ability to translate that into
worship and connection with god that's
really lovely
so um good evening everyone grace and
peace
welcome to the table my name is brett
i'm the pastor here and
i'm really glad that you've joined us
live
uh that you're skipping out on those
cowboys
dallas cowboys are blind or that you're
recording it that's what i'm doing uh
so yeah thanks for uh for being here and
it's it's actually a really um kind of
important night because we are
um kicking off a brand new series uh
titled scripture
dealing with difficult texts uh and
honestly this may be one of the most
important series that we have done here
at the table
um because just kind of throughout it
we're gonna be tackling
some really thorny uh often you know
upsetting passages in the scriptures if
you've ever
um found yourself reading the bible and
just coming across something that you're
like
i don't know how to reconcile that with
christ you know
um you know this series is for that so
um for example we'll cover kind of
everything from you know how do we
understand texts that would seem to
advocate violence against gay people or
texts that uh scriptures you know that
seem to demean women what about passages
that describe god as
very violent or that describe how the
mass of humanity will
roast in hell forever you know what what
do we do with those passages how do we
understand them
and uh and how do we make sense of them
in light of the love of christ
right that's really the key question
because this isn't just about like
putting our personal preferences ahead
of god or something
or um not caring about the bible or the
faith or
it's not about that right it's it's like
how do i make sense of this in light of
the
love of god in christ like that's the
thing
um and so those the kind of questions
that we'll be will be going through over
the next six weeks or so
um now two of our values here at the
table are to be
an inclusive uh as well as an eclectic
community inclusive eclectic which
frankly
that that means that we do not all agree
on everything let's just get that out of
the way first um we don't all agree
and so as we go through the series you
may find yourself disagreeing with me
um disagreeing with how i approach the
scriptures as a whole
um disagreeing with how maybe just i
handle a particular issue uh that's okay
you are you're welcome to disagree uh in
fact we can totally disagree and still
be friends
uh we can disagree and still serve and
leave the same church
that's what it means to be an inclusive
christian community so if you're
you know going through at any point in
the series and you're like oh no
i think i think i'm more theologically
liberal than brett or
oh no i think i'm more theologically
conservative
uh chill out that's okay i i just don't
believe that ideological purity or sheer
group
think is a sign of health it's not a
virtue in an organization
in fact that's one of the hallmarks of a
cult and i have no interest
in leading such an organization so i
just want to kind of set you at ease
it's okay we're just we're just
wrestling with some really
thorny difficult passages and um i'll do
my best
you do your best and uh we can be
friends
and and work this through so um so today
as we kind of kick things off
rather than jumping right into you know
the various topics
i actually wanted to kind of step back a
bit and talk
about how i understand scripture as a
whole think i
because if i jumped right in i think the
question you're back in the back of your
mind would be like what is brett
how does he think of the scriptures um
you know yeah like where is he coming
from on this so i wanted to kind of
just address that right here at the
beginning and i think that will set us
up really well
to later then jump into those more
difficult passages
and i think it'll make sense how i'm
coming at it
so again you may not agree but at least
it'll make sense
so with that in mind the title of my
message tonight
is an ancient approach to the bible
and our primary text is going to be john
chapter 5 verses 39 through 40
where jesus himself speaking to a group
of religious
authorities says this you study the
scriptures diligently
because you think that in them you
have eternal life these
are the very scriptures that testify
about me
yet you refuse to come to me
to have life now if i could choose
one passage that just sums up
my view of how the scriptures function
in the life of the church and in the
life of an individual
follower of christ that passage that
would be it right there
uh and i think the the key word in in
this passage is
testify or we might use the word
testimony
right jesus says the scriptures testify
about
me uh so i grew up in a church where
everyone but especially the youth would
occasionally share their testimonies
so i know that's kind of a churchy word
but i'll unpack it so for example if you
went on like a
a weekend retreat you know to get away
and be with god or
maybe to a summer church camp or you
went on a mission trip
where you go to a different culture to
maybe connect with the ministry there
um what you would do is you would come
back and everyone would gather at the
church
on sunday night and the adults would all
very patiently listen perhaps a better
word is endure
uh we the teenagers are very long-winded
um hours
of us teens sharing our testimonies
and of course the point of a testimony
is to point to god right in other words
a good testimony is
not well i went to church camp and it
was like so great because i was with my
friends
and we like had so much fun
and the food wasn't even too bad
um no that's sort of missing the point
right the point of a testimony
is to point to christ it is to say i
went and had this experience
and here is what god did here is how i
experienced him here is how i
sensed him leading me here is what i saw
god up to in myself and
in others right the point of a testimony
is to point to god to christ to the holy
spirit
but here's the key idea no one um
no one worships the testimony itself
right no one says oh my gosh the
foundation
of my faith the center of my life the
thing i am staking
everything on is the purity the
perfection the holiness
of people's testimonies about god
no why because the point of a testimony
is not to point to the awesomeness of
the speaker
it is to point to god and and yes of
course
um certain testimonies are more
trustworthy than others
based on the integrity and reputation of
that speaker but ultimately
the speaker is not the main attraction
even the testimony itself
is not the main attraction rather it is
the one
we are speaking of that
is the point there's an old zen
saying that you may have heard uh it's
the finger is not the moon
you ever heard this a finger is not the
moon so it's supposed to be
kind of an image so imagine
that the sun has set and the moon is
beginning to emerge
it's just it's one of those nights where
the moon it is full and bright and
beautiful
and so i i point to the moon
and uh you look at my finger right i'm
kind of pointing off
and you you look at my finger and you
say oh
what what are you doing why are you
doing that
that with your hand and i say no no no
no look look the the moon
and you say the moon
your finger is not the moon and i say
i know look look what i'm pointing at
stop looking at my finger
and look over there at the moon and
finally you turn and you say oh
wow that's really something right this
is precisely the point i think jesus
in john chapter 5 is making about the
scriptures
he is saying my friends you are obsessed
with the perfect form of the arm
and the tilts of the finger
pointing i wish you could be half as
obsessed
with the reality that sacred text
is pointing to namely christ
says me it is testimony
to me in other words the point of
scripture
is to point to jesus you see
jesus is the word the communication the
revelation of god
jesus is the head of the church
jesus is lord the bible
scripture is testimony pointing to
that word right the bible is the finger
pointing to the greater more important
more essential reality
it's a bit like the man who was
traveling by foot to london and so he
comes to a fork in the path
so he's got a decision to make and
there's a sign and it says the word
london
with an arrow pointing to the left and
the man reads the sign
and says oh london
i'm here wow not as good as i thought it
would be
uh now we would laugh at that man
because we know
the point of the sign is not the sign
itself
the point of a sign is what it signifies
right the greater reality
to which it points
and so this is what the bible is it's
this incredibly
diverse story of god's interaction with
humanity
written across millennia by wildly
different people coming from wildly
different contexts and cultures
and it's written in a variety of
different
genres i mean the bible has it all like
we think of it kind of as
a book because you know it's bound
together in one book but really it's
this
it's a it's a collection right it's like
a library and there is
um i mean everything there's mythology
in poetry
history letters prayers prophecy
apocalyptic
wisdom literature and and i would
contend uh
that i mean the just the vast majority
of it majority of it is it is compelling
and beautiful particularly by the time
you get to jesus in the new testament
right there's just so much
insight so many passages that continue
to
deepen and challenge me i mean that's
why i preach from the bible
every single week right and you can
never exhaust
i can never exhaust it never come to the
end of it it's like this
piece of art whose meaning always
exceeds any one interpretation
or reading that's how you know it's good
when you keep coming back to it and
finding something new the holy spirit
continues to faithfully use the bible to
speak to generation
after generation why because it is a
faithful sign pointing to a reality
that continues to call to us
and draw us towards god
now having said that from the earliest
days of christianity
you find that the most thoughtful
uh christian theologians these were
kind of the the thinkers of of you know
early christian faith
um and these poor folks um you know by
the way who are very
kind of legit i mean if anything they
were the ones kind of fighting what they
perceived as like the heresy
you know so these were like orthodox
people i believe in the actual
crucifixion resurrection of jesus i
believe that through him myself and
you know all creation is being saved i
mean it's those kind of folks right and
they
but here's what they understood they
understood
that to simply read the bible as a
flat text what i mean is where every
passage
is is equally as relevant and as
inspired as every other passage
where every single verse carries the
exact same weight and authority
as every other verse where if the bible
says and then god did such and such or
then god told the israelites to do such
and such and you just
read it just totally literally rather
than
figuratively or symbolically they
totally
understood that if you did that
you could end up with a religion that
looked and sounded
absolutely nothing like jesus christ
they they totally understood this and
the reason i'm emphasizing this
um is is just to get through our heads
uh that this tradition this way of
reading the bible is
very ancient i mean it's frankly how the
early church was doing it
um even paul the apostle paul in places
like
did this uh because they understood
that at times the way god
is described in the old testament in
particular you could argue parts of the
new but
mostly it's the old um that there are
certainly places where god is described
in how do you say it i mean if you've
ever read the bible i'm presuming you've
come across these texts
um maybe i'm wearing my crazy pants
today but i'm assuming you've come
across it like
god's described in how do you say
awkward
kind of weird almost zeus-like ways
uh what do i mean by zeus like i mean a
uh
a lowercase g god who
is basically kind of like a superhuman
kind of like superman you know very
powerful can throw the thunderbolts
but who is still quite limited a
lowercase g god who can be for example
like
tricked you know who kind of has to
think and ponder things like
oh okay give me a second i gotta think
this through
um a god who can feel
you know insecure uh
uh lowercase g god who feels kind of
jealous
like you don't you don't love me enough
how could you how could you do that to
me
spurn my love uh just to be clear that's
a
a zeus like if you take it very very
literally
that's a zeus-like god which is to say
you know a demigod a a super-duper
powerful being
but who themselves were still created by
something greater um
not you know capital g god
the source of all it is now perhaps
you're thinking like wait
what no no
it can't be well if you're saying that i
think maybe you haven't read the bible
but
but i'll be you know let me kind of back
this up a little bit so let me give you
a few examples
um i mean there's all there's many
passages i could go through
i mean there's all sorts of oh gosh i
was just reading the other day um
and uh i'm into uh the book of jeremiah
there's a passage
there where the lord kind of describes
how he's going to basically shame the
israelites for their unfaithfulness and
so
the text says he's going to lift the
skirts of the women
over their heads and it's kind of a
euphemism for
basically rape like it's just like
uh that's a good example there's one in
ezekiel that's this image
he says i will um i'm going to where's
isaiah ezekiel or isaiah maybe isaiah
because i just finished your united
states
but it's the passage where he's
describing god's describing how um he's
i mean he's really super pissed
and so he's like i'm going to tread
down all of you people as the um
as the grape stomper shreds
the wine press so i will tread you
it's kind of the image if you ever can
imagine like the way someone's stomping
on grapes and the image there is like
the humans basically i mean it's really
kind of like
okay yeah that's really violent
um or here's one in um let me give you a
few examples from genesis so in genesis
um and these are so much about violence
those other two were about violence um
but but in genesis 2 you have the second
creation myth
if you've ever read it closely you know
there's actually it describes two
separate ones
genesis 1 genesis 2. and so here's an
example where if you do a very flat just
literal pitilessly literal reading of
the text of that story
um then you know it's it's it comes
across a little bit silly so i mean
uh for example you could probably rename
the story the fable of how the snake
lost its feet
uh and in this story you have god you
know acting a little bit insecure
because basically places you know that
you um adam and eve like in the garden
and he tells them hey
you know um you can eat of you know all
the trees but just
um not of the tree of the knowledge of
good and evil because if you do that
you will surely die but actually as you
read the story
um that's not totally true because later
he has to say like as they of course eat
you know
and then he says like he's talking it
kind of the image you get is almost the
pantheon of other gods like
are you always kind of consulting and
saying like okay we gotta do something
we gotta um
if they stay in the garden and they eat
of the immortal tree of life
well then they will actually be immortal
like us and never die and so okay we
can't have that can we
so god kind of kicks them you know out
of the garden and then curses the snake
right so that the snake loses his feet
and has to slither around from this day
forward
um now just to be clear if you're like
brett you're mocking the bible i'm not
mocking
i'm saying i could actually today to
well not today because i have one
prepared
next week i could totally preach a
sermon on genesis 2 could preach many
right it's an amazing story tons of
insight into our experience
as humans it's amazing what i'm saying
is that red as a literal
story of how the snake lost its feet
as a literal story with an expected
flawless description of the attributes
and character of god
it's uh it's super problematic
put it like that uh the same goes for
just a few chapters later
in genesis 11 there's the story of the
tower of babel
and again read in a kind of spiritual
figurative way
it's remarkably insightful read as an
actual literal story of how the people
of the world
came to speak different languages read
as a literal story with some kind of
perfect description of the attributes
and character of god
it's problematic right if you recall the
story goes now that human beings
discover
this remarkable technology called the
brick
and so they begin to build up into the
heavens it says
and so yahweh who's sort of you know the
leader again of like the pantheon of
other gods most people think of the
bible as a monotheistic
book in terms of teachers where's one
god uh
that's not exactly true it's like sort
of the high god but then there's a
in the early texts there's certain
understanding of like pantheon of god
um so he's kind of again consulting with
the gods
and he basically says like uh-oh
these humans are building way up high
and the unspoken assumption like the
text doesn't quite come out and say but
it seems to be
that they might be able to build
high enough to eventually reach god
uh and so apparently god you know it's
feeling a little bit insecure
and so says like hey these humans are
doing too many amazing things
um we've got to go down and confuse
their language
so that they uh they won't build so high
and that's why today some people speak
hebrew
and others speak mandarin or french uh
now like i said uh it's it's a very
powerful story about human culture and
psychology and hubris and i mean i'm
sure
rob bell if you all know of some of you
know rebels you know good preacher
he rob belvin he could preach like three
stinking amazing sermons on that passage
and you would all be like wow incredible
god is so speaking to me
and and i'm not knocking that like i
think that's true the holy spirit can
use that story can use that passage
um to speak to it's it's an incredible
story
but let's be clear robel when he
preaches that
he is going to preach a figurative
symbolic message he's not going to argue
now um scientifically this is why some
people speak french
no and he's certainly not going to build
his doctrine
of the nature and character of god
from that story because otherwise
you'll have an understanding of god as
this kind of
weird insecure zeus like character who's
very worried
like zeus that zeus kind of worried the
greeks were going to scale mount olympus
only now instead of a mountain in this
story
it's a you know 100 foot high pyramid
um okay so as you're listening you might
be thinking barrett is one of those
modern liberal readers of the bible um
no this is my point what i'm saying is
i'm simply reading the bible
like the apostle paul like the like the
super old people not your grandparents i
mean
the ancient christians origin gregory of
nissa
thomas aquinas saint augustine
i'm just reading it like them because as
i was naming above um
they they knew all of this
like right this is this is what's
amazing it's just a there's a side note
this is not my notes but i'm just going
um like this is why you know folks who
leave the faith like
you know atheist agnostics often read
the bible and they're just like well
this is dumb
you know and they think i think they
don't understand
that really the like thousands millions
of christians throughout history
don't just read a story like the tower
of babel
and just read it literally and like they
don't
no no like no we can use our brains
right so
this is um this this is this is not
brett the modernist thinking
thoughts the silly ancients because
isn't that kind of arrogant like where
the geniuses now we see that the bible
has some problematic parts
those silly ancient people they didn't
they weren't morons
like they did it they know right they
knew that for
all of its beauty and revelation of
course
they knew the bible could be read in
ways that would make god sound like some
sort of joke
like so here this is a line from uh
gregory of nissa
truly one of the great uh he's the
greatest
not greatest but one of the great early
christian theologians um
talking you know first few hundred years
of the faith and he says this if one
does not read scripture
in a philosophical he means by this kind
of an allegorical or figurative fashion
uh one is reading only myths with
contradictory narratives
right there's in and if you're thinking
oh gregor he was he must have been a
heretic no
no no greggy he was orthodox like
trying to keep the crazy at bay i mean
no
he knows right he gets he knows um
here's this is a passage uh from
augustine
saint augustine in his book titled a
literal reading of genesis
which coincidentally is actually
anything but what we would think of
as literal in the modern sense uh and so
and
even here augustine like he knows to you
know to read the early chapters of
genesis right the whole creation and
stuff
as you know as pure science or something
he's like yeah
so this is what he writes um usually
even a non-christian will know like know
something about the earth the heavens
and the other elements
of the world about the motion and orbit
of the stars even their size and
relative positions about the predictable
eclipses of the sun and the moon
the cycles of the years and the seasons
about the kinds of animals shrub stones
and so forth
and this knowledge he holds to as being
certain from reason and experience
now it is a disgraceful and dangerous
thing
for an infidel it's kind of a weird term
it just means you know
non-believer to hear a christian
presumably giving the meaning of holy
scripture
talking nonsense on these topics
and we should take all means to prevent
such an embarrassing situation
he continues later if they find a
christian
mistaken in a field he's thinking here
like scientific field
which they themselves know well and they
hear him maintaining his
foolish opinions about our books how are
they going to believe
those books in matters concerning right
here's the list of the important things
the key things
the resurrection of the dead the hope of
eternal life
and the kingdom of heaven when they
think
their pages are full of falsehoods on
facts which they themselves have learned
from experience
and the light of reason reckless
and incompetent expounders of holy
scripture
bring untold trouble and sorrow
on their wiser brethren ah
in other words saint augustine he would
not have kind words for the very
well-meaning christians
who for example try and explain away the
dinosaur fossil record
because they think god's word is under
attack
no stop let the scientists do their
science and if you want to push back
you know with other science we'll go for
it but don't
no don't use genesis 1 for that note now
you say well but brett
gustin he's talking about sciency things
which i get i get brad i get what you're
saying but but what you're saying really
is more radical you're saying
that when i read the bible i can't
always just take it at face value
but i have to sort of discern do
i read this literally or do i read it
kind of figuratively or spiritually or
something
uh but how would i know how to do that
brett i mean i mean
like how how does this this kind of
figurative approach like how do i even
know
when to do it like when it when it
begins and ends i mean before you know
it you're going to have me thinking
christ's resurrection is figurative and
allegorical all right so let me clarify
here
this is another quote from saint
augustine this is kind of his his rule
for how you read the bible well
which i think christians in our culture
could use a lot more of
uh he says this in the first place then
we must show
the way to find out whether a phrase is
literal or figurative right because
that's the that's the question right how
do i know when i come to a verse
what do i do with this and he says this
the way is certainly as follows
whatever there is in the word of god
that cannot when taken literally
be referred either to purity of life or
soundness of doctrine
you may set down as figurative
purity of life has reference to the love
of god
in one's neighbor soundness of doctrine
to the knowledge of god
and one's neighbor so what is augustine
doing here he's basically saying
look um you're adults presumably many of
you have
read the gospels you know the love and
character of christ
which means you know the love and
character of god so if you come across
something in the bible
that seems to contradict that
then not as a secularist not as someone
who just loves to doubt the bible not as
someone who wants to prove their
spiritual superiority to others
but as someone simply committed to
christ in his kingdom of
love and committed to read the bible
well you are
impelled to read it figuratively in fact
saint augustine just give you kind of an
example of this saint augustine went so
far
as to re-read this is an old testament
now this is the new testament he
reread the story of christ clearing the
temple
uh some of you if you've read that story
he cleared a temple uh with a whip
and so augustine saint augustine he
actually read that figuratively he said
this did not happen uh because he
basically said oh come on
christ would never do that this must be
talking about the way
and this is the figurative metaphorical
reading he says but what this is
a parable this is talking about the way
christ
drives the sin from our hearts
um now on that one i actually disagree
with augustine there i don't think jesus
the way i interpret that passage i don't
think he was literally whipping people
and drawing blood like
i think the the image is kind of
cracking the whip over the heads of the
people
driving them out with his prophetic
words you have turned this you know
house of prayer into a den of thieves
get out of here
so i that's how i read it i don't see
the need to read that figuratively
but hey maybe i'm wrong maybe
augustine's onto something the point is
that
when we come to the bible uh we come to
it like adults with as my kindergarten
teacher used to say
but your thinking caps on right we
that's how we come to the bible as
adults with our thinking caps on
brains fully engaged ready to
question ready to wrestle ready to study
and
and this isn't just about the intellect
also ready to
spiritually hear from god
right ready for the holy spirit to speak
to
us and to lead us in
um and by the way in every passage this
is why if you're like brett is saying we
should throw out the bible
what no that is exactly not what i'm
saying i'm saying god can use and will
use
the entire text of scripture to speak
truth to us but
sometimes for him to do that we're going
to read a text
in a figurative a metaphorical a
symbolic
rather than a um literal
kind of way
so that's a lot of words but i hope you
can see
um now why i
personally can be both very critical of
a
certain kind of simplistic literal
approach to every chapter and verse in
the bible
while at the same time i can also be
someone
who reads this text i mean almost every
day of my life
and i love it i believe it
is powerful compelling
and a faithful sign
pointing to the work of god in christ
in the world but here's the key i don't
worship the sign i don't demand
that the sign itself be flawless
uh or or greater than that to which it
points or else i'm leaving the faith or
no no it is after all right the text
it's the finger
pointing to the moon it's pointing
to the love of god in christ
that's the point right the point of
scripture is to point
to christ so i hope that you'll join us
in the weeks ahead as we look at some
difficult passages
just to see how we might understand them
afresh and anew all right let me pray
for you
lord jesus um we ask
that in this series lord that you would
guide us
into truth
and that you would we trust
or we trust your spirit that as we
engage the bible your spirit will lead
us
you'll teach us you'll show us how to
read the bible well
and may we stop hurting people with the
bible
may we stop condemning may we stop
representing you in ways that aren't
really in line
with your character god help us to do
that
in a powerful life-changing name of
jesus i pray
amen
thanks brett that is a lot to chew on
and think through and i'm excited for
the next few weeks to
wrestle through these passages together
um
as brett told me what he was going to be
talking about
there was a video that common hymnal you
guys
have heard me mention common hymnal i am
a big fan of their music
and what they're um about
and they um had this video of a song
that they produced called
god is not abusive and i wanted to take
some time tonight to watch that together
and as we go into this song i know for
me anyways
a lot of times um i'm drawn to
the music that is catchy that gets in my
head that i can re-sing
easily um and this wasn't one of those
songs for me personally it might be for
someone else but for me
i experienced it almost like i
experienced a painting
that someone makes for me where i'm
standing in front
of this work of art and um
some an artist friend of mine um chris
deruel one time
said instead of someone clearly telling
you the meaning of
their painting instead maybe go and
stand in front of it
and let the painting speak to you
and that's what this song was like for
me it was like experiencing art it was
like standing there
and letting it speak to me not even just
the words although they are
powerful and potent words um but also
the musicality
was just almost like receiving
art and um so i hope that we can engage
this together
and receive what it has for us um in
this song
so um scott's gonna go ahead and put
that up for us and then we'll come back
together
[Music]
god is not abusive
takes no pleasure in our shame
he finds a place inside
[Music]
lay down every stone
bearing guilt from mother's
sins
[Music]
jesus
draws is to these kindness
[Music]
he will not come
to not be afraid
these burdens no longer
need to keep you
silent
[Music]
there's refuge from
all the hurts and pains
[Music]
[Applause]
these burdens no longer
[Music]
god is not abusive
takes no pleasure in our
shape
he finds a place inside our paint
thanks can you guys um if you know this
just
sing it with me as we kind of start to
close out our service
um together these words felt
so powerful and fresh for me after
watching that video
jesus loves me this
i know for
the bible tells me
so little ones to
him be long
they are weak
but he is strong
yes jesus
loves me
loves me the
bible tells me
[Music]
so
thank you mindy i love that and
um yeah i really appreciate those words
and being able to reflect on it
um just with a whole new perspective as
you guys
go into your weeks we just want to send
you with a blessing
um and um courage we're praying great
things over you
feel free to go to our website
thetabletx.com
to find out more information on how you
could get connected with a meetup group
to connect with other people during the
week and support one another
or to find out how you could give and
contribute to the work we're doing at
the table
um both of those can be found on our
website thetabletx.com
and i wanted to read this one blessing
benediction over you guys this is a
franciscan
benediction and it says may god
bless us with discomfort at easy answers
half truths and superficial
relationships
that we may live deep within our hearts
may god bless us with anger and
injustice
oppression and exploitation of people
so that we may work for freedom justice
and peace may god bless us with tears to
shed for those who suffer from
pain from rejection starvation
and war so that we may reach out our
hands
to comfort them and to turn their pain
into joy
may god bless us with enough foolishness
to believe that we can make a difference
in this world
so that we can do what others claim
cannot be done amen
go with god goodbye
you